what is happening there reject Nation
Greg and John here today to watch the
new Disney movie chip and Dale's Rescue
Rangers now full disclosure I have no
familiarity with Chip and Dales on the
other hand he has grew up on chip and
Dale's Rescue Rangers but this movie
should tend to all anywho guys thank you
so much for being here you can catch the
full-length watch along We sync over the
timecoder for super sexy Rejects at our
patreon page cover a bunch of shows over
there as well some shows have exclusive
reaction highlights included and if you
can't do that please leave a like that'd
be very much appreciated and your
thoughts on this movie Down Below also
subscribe for the notification Bell if
you follow the channel already you'll
see we've been covering quite a bit of
movies and shows already lastly thanks
to the Boys At prepper if you guys are
in need of an editor they are a great
people great a great people to work with
a great people to a great a great people
good night's people of interesting to
work with all right let's do this
[Music]
cool
what's the first thing that pops into
your head when I say Chip and Dale
Rescue Rangers the london-based cabinet
maker from the 1700s sit cabinet Thomas
but I bet the second thing that pops
into your head are these guys yes but
certainly third would be those rascally
cartoon chipmunks Chip and Dale everyone
say hello to Dale hello everyone nice to
meet you
I know
that's cool
[Music]
I'm fine you're weird
oh God people weren't kidding thing no
one wanted anything to do with me
so I had to sit alone
[Music]
oh
hey
mind if I sit oh I I have that lunchbox
it was excellent comic timing really I
kind of wish I hadn't done it no way man
the biggest risk is not taking any risk
at all themes the chip was so funny and
thoughtful about everything and I never
thought about anything we were perfect
together
wow that's cool he introduced me some
music Crust Pizza funny old movies
even the old movies got cartoons in them
hey
we knew we had something special
[Laughter]
by the way we never saw trailers for
this so this is our first look at
everything yep I didn't know it was
going to be this animation style yeah
Roger Rabbit yeah this will be a
completely authentic reaction and after
landing a few small parts we finally got
the call
our own TV show it was about a group of
little detectives who would solve big
crimes there was the adventurer monterey
jack
the inventor Gadget hack wrench and
zipper
with chip as The Logical straight man
and me as the fun-loving goof
up wow
yeah I've never seen any of this oh yeah
it's taking me back that's a rough folks
nice work everyone
this is so much like Roger Rabbit never
in my wildest dreams did I think we'd be
here now so do you Dell my best friend
and to all of you to everyone who loves
a short toast
that's not her actual voice isn't it we
were living the dreams high on the hog
all night long dancing to Roger Rabbit
with Roger
cool oh my God
double oh Dale that's hilarious what is
that it's wild right it's my new show
I'm gonna be a super spy new show uh oh
why didn't you talk to me about it first
we tell each other everything I just
wanted to make sure the show was gonna
happen first before I got your hopes up
my hopes what oh if you do this they
might cancel the show no they won't do
that everyone knows you're the favorite
and I'm just the guy who gets hit in the
head with a pipe each week it's fine I
did think chip was a bit cooler I'm a
little more popular than you do you know
how dumb that is
I am the dumb one
oh John oh
that's why never embraced my inner tail
do not do it
go for Dale
John and I had this exact conversation
we could go sorry man
couldn't turn down the show biz life it
wasn't anyone's fault in particular just
one of those Showbiz things
oh but now we're ready to bring it back
oh my god oh snap this is in chapter one
of Dale's Tales if you liked it please
don't forget to subscribe below he's an
influencer yeah with an iPhone 4 and a
gamer Thor
[Music]
[Applause]
cool of course they believe the
qualities for you what is this movie
I love it
oh my
ugly Sonic no there you go kid
oh they're laughing at me I know that
you can't hurt my feelings if I'm in on
the joke are you though wow today
I've been offered a new reality show
where I do ride-alongs with the FBI a TV
show you yeah is that so difficult to
believe oh
oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
I should give him a call see how life's
treating him life is the worst washed up
which is why you need good insurance oh
no here are made 2D yeah man I did so
long not too deep but you know I mean
hand drawn I'll take the whole package
fantastic you're making the right choice
coercive and sure this is how Space Jam
a new Legacy should have been done I
know God take notes wanna get a drink to
celebrate sorry everyone can't tonight
Millie's waiting for me are you sure you
don't want to see my new pad
frog-based humor no thanks just a taste
of what you get from me outside the work
environment
foreign
or Salma Hayek or something
always doing [ __ ] was brutal
last two months cartoons missing frozo
Foods
Ruby so many Easter eggs
the Chipmunks
on this time
[Laughter]
this time they're rapping they're
rapping they always have to make the
cartoons rap
yeah that's what we like because we're
young people and we rats when we
identify
fellow children I got your voicemail you
said you were in trouble uh I screwed up
chip my love of cheese got the best of
me
I'm literally gonna joke that
why should I throw my cheesecake now I
owe a ton of money to the valley King
did you hear what happened that little
guy flounder when he fell behind on
Krill payments oh
[Laughter]
and change him around to try and snake
by the copyright blues and then
he will spend the rest of his life being
forced to make Terrible
bootlegm No Te AWA leak
you look the same yeah thanks and you
look different ah hey it's no secret I
had the CGI surgery done
Monty if you're really in trouble you
know how to find me Dale
you were also here
[Music]
doesn't sound like he's actually over a
Squidward
I can read the others reboot I think
they can squeeze a dollar fast furious
babies babies take the wheel I've been
fine without it oh no Mr Doubtfire
better Chun-Li
it's Justice for John Lee
Batman versus at yeah
well who was on the Gucci poster dang
hang after the show tonight I know a
great place for cheesy crust pizza I'm
sorry man but we got other plans you
know
oh my God is he working at actual
Chippendales I think he might just be
[Music]
fun
ha
yeah right like that would happen
how to save a copy yeah good
Chip's a bootlegger I just got a call
from the police and Monty's been
kidnapped what are you serious yeah I'm
gonna head back to his apartment I'll
meet you there
cars how many intellectual properties
here they're more than Disney yeah they
must just throwing down some money
[Music]
yo oh this is so impressive you're the
friends of the victim you got anything
for me any known enemies or
stop motion JK Simmons Sweet Pete's got
his fingers in every illegal business
from bootleg into stinky cheese getting
rich while we look like we just fell off
the turnip truck
you're scared the beans out of me
Steckler sorry sir why don't you just
leave the real detective work to me okay
right sorry sir Chief depressor
[Music]
oh my God but if you guys can find that
bootlegging facility I think you'll find
your friend wow
and thank you again for watching this
show it really means a lot you are gross
I'll be in touch you're amazing
it's a trap she's trapping them yeah
she's too too nice I can't just let him
rot in some overseas Studio being forced
to make bad movies if he's gonna make
bad movies he should be making them here
shot we have no idea where to start we
don't even know what we're
geez
who moved the cheese
so you're saying the Rescue Rangers are
back no because there's no such thing as
Rescue Rangers case closed case no this
is not a case because we're not real
detectives no but you did say case yeah
oh you damn right it's a case clever
another clever movie yeah I think I know
my own character chip and he wears a top
hat
wrong side of the tracks uh this place
is pretty shady it's the wrong side of
the tracks because nothing's safe
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's like Disneyland Main Street
stolen Social Security numbers
Muppet fights
the Happy Time murders happening across
town do you have any cheese for sale
we've got the Munster
do you have any stinky cheese
cops hahaha
[Music]
this really is like a spiritual sequel
to Roger Rabbit yeah take a look at this
photo it's a friend of mine named
monterey jack which is also the name of
a cheese
my boss sweet pete he loves actors I
think you should meet him we were about
to get kicked out with your plan and now
thanks to my sweet improv we're going to
see sweet peas oh you're insane am I of
course you'd rather just give up
[Laughter]
we're here
the way they've blooded all these
different styles together is fantastic
yeah it's beautiful
Justice for cats
can't eat them
weird animation style in the early 2000s
oh yeah everything looked real but
nothing is Right still happens sometimes
so genitalical children
what that's Seth Rogen who are you
oh wow
I can't tell oh
[ __ ] who are you well right but In
fairness it looks like you're talking to
that window nope it actually looks like
I'm looking right at you
look at my eyes looking right at your
eyes
[Music]
those are chipmunks hello
wow
no you can't say nothing to me I haven't
heard already Jimmy please untie our
guests Will Arnett right yeah I think so
I recruited other Tunes to Star and more
movies and Jasper the dead ghosts
spaghetti dogs
oh I'm thinking it's time for a Chip and
Dale reboot Jimmy you come with me yep
we're dead
whoa ready
[Music]
hey that's my personal bathroom
ponytail
the water slide oh damn it okay
ah [ __ ] no no I'm done
[Music]
[Applause]
laughs
[Laughter]
I want to live in this reality we didn't
learn anything of value except for that
sweet pete wears the same step tracker
that I do do they keep track of
everywhere you go yeah I know because I
like to map my runs in the shape of a
butt
I think I can't promise that
the Lord commits to the genre so much
yeah stylistically the way
cinematography is too it's like someone
who cares
at least catching it I think I have
exactly what we need don't move he's
running he's out from Palm Springs
[Music]
oh my
[Music]
bro I had that game
ah got him oh calories not included
throw mummy from the train dirty rotten
diaper I had to read write a typer hey
see you're part of the club wow so cool
I know right unfortunately I only have
11 of the 12. I'm missing the main one
of all of us together
ah it's just old junk yeah he has it uh
oh I say we have about an hour before
anyone notices this van is missing so
wow Shake a tail that is a high-tech van
don't do your bad New York accent chip I
hear you but it's an unreasonable ask yo
we're here to clean the pipe did you
forget about it
yeah and hot dogs bagels and pizza
a coffee and I'm walking here a taxi
[Music]
hey YouTube
YouTube this water fountain good
are the pipes clean to drink from oh
hey hey they're cleaner than broadway
baby I'm walking here
nice work you need to stay up on those
pipes out of sight yep on it
ah that feels great man oh yeah
come on
[Music]
seriously how many properties are in
this
ah there it is
[Music]
yikes oh you're the Rescue Rangers I
huge fanboy
oh
no way is this a remix of the Disney
Afternoon theme song you made this you
are knowing it brother now you do a rap
on it yes oh I don't know give me one
second with Dahlia bro to the rap
are not rabbit right there's nothing oh
no old cartoon character trying to seem
cool again like rap ship I hear you but
I don't think we have much of it oh no
here I go
I'm about to kick it oh no and I'm in
hell
[Laughter]
my name is Dale I don't eat whale why
would you say can I eat whale
once you're out of jail you can't think
of anything else
scale whale pale rail tail hail snail
kale Braille
[Music]
it was like professional same time Jay
CE you owe me a non-brand specific Cola
that was crazy
but this is incredible
yeah but your bad rapping was the
perfect distraction so good thanks I
totally thought we were busted but then
you just fully went for it
for it you busted some Rhymes
San Pedro Ducks yes we got him I feel
good who's watching your dog
is pee everywhere in your house now
spend you for going behind my back
stickler and I hope we don't get
attacked by the Rugrats this time
ready the battering ram the regular
Rugrats to the grown-up ones
did Akiva director who from Lonely
Island Akiva uh okay that makes more
sense than genre styles sir whoa I think
I found some this was Justice I'm
if I can't find a light switch wait no
no no no no no no no no
see nothing to worry about I guess
you're right
uh oh no what have you done
[Music]
you could have made it in there
the machine is going to try and
surgically re-edit you so try to avoid
that he's gonna switch bodies
at Waffle pride no I think it's scanning
them and rendering what they'll look
like in different animations
oh my God cool
two minute a name
come on shoot that wire do you remember
I guess a couple things are coming back
to me then let's do it how different
could it be very different
[Laughter]
it's like it was designed for them it's
probably designed watching that episode
what
oh my Jimmy Neutron's hair look at all
these parts
oh no
oh Mustang oh my God it's a serial
killer yeah
it's twisted he's been bootlegged
It's Time to Get Some Guns yeah
chip a tailor back should we try to
follow them nah let him go I have my own
special way of tracking people
it's like the Matrix transition music
yeah I'm telling you we're missing
something I can feel it Dale hey just
want to remind you guys I'll be at Fan
con this afternoon signing autographs so
get those nuts ready what is wrong with
you what it's my job it's a choice
chip doesn't understand
I've been holding on to this for some
stupid reason
now your collection is complete wait
then
I didn't even want to do to upload deal
what I think I just wanted you to tell
me you needed me
oh
I need you John
sometimes
don't get carried away
but
grab the token you you left the puck
here
oh my God the chief is corrupt fonte was
literally the only person to ever use
that disgusting cologne putty's office
stunk of it which means someone had
Senator bud has got my vote putty's 2
yes think Dale
time
said right away
[Music]
you don't have a show with the FBI I
knew it I love that ugly Sonic gets to
live on that's great Justice for ugly
Sonic originally
[Laughter]
what are you done got you
what are you looking at honestly you're
weird
[Laughter]
beautiful
oh my goodness
you want a piece of me
there's the exit
chip where are you
is it the same with the convention
center paint that place you should have
just let me bootleg you when you came
into my office could have saved us both
a ton of headaches ah dip was always
more of an Alvin and the Chipmunks
person
I grew up in Alvin the Chipmunks how
about you freeze
it is him oh
how could you money I'm a greedy little
Smurf who did it for the money
hahaha
I'm down at the bootlegging facility
meet me here
and come along well that sounds super
shady and not safe at all I know but you
have to trust me
and you fish upon a star that's my
favorite episode there's a clue deep cut
why is that your favorite
[Laughter]
all right think Dale think Gadget is
stuck in a lantern lanterns provide
light
[ __ ]
good
Ellie has ten toes and she probably
likes Thai food Ellie is tied up and in
dangerous
yes
[Music]
that was great it was beautiful that was
so good
thank you
there's never the joke is no that
doesn't make any sense to her but did
they figure it out the love out got
there oh my goodness
[Music]
yeah I need your help we love you bud
well we just can't invest in any more of
your independent movies
okay let's make some changes
oh yeah Dave bolinari haven't heard from
you in a while did you not get my last
seven years of messages oh daily
I think for the first time in my life I
am getting my priorities straight
friends are more important than business
[Laughter]
oh buddy
[Music]
hey hey fix that you should fix it
[Music]
foreign
oh my God cronenberg's Peter Pan
oh yeah what do you like snake in my
boot
[ __ ] huh
you got his voice
[Music]
that actually made me dizzy ah finally
somebody acknowledges that
all the headbutts you see in movies
[Applause]
now do it okay here I go
I can't believe we
every week come on where are they
I was about to ask ah this isn't good
huh
yeah
oh good call back goodbye Chip and Dale
ugly Sonic hit it
[Music]
[Music]
oh my God they should cross over an
Alvin and the Chipmunks yes
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
that looks painful
I never told you this but I begged my
mom to let me stay home from school
because I didn't have any friends I
needed you
more than you needed me no
that's sweet really
help
but how'd you this thing's too special
to throw away
[Music]
oh hey do you think we could get like a
pop star to do the theme song yeah right
like a super serious version even though
everyone just wants to hear the original
[Laughter]
[Music]
man this is like a real movie though oh
my goodness it really was Zach that's a
theater movie in a lot of ways
yeah I like I would definitely want to
go and see this in a theater yeah
like I'm bummed I never got to see Roger
Rabbit so this would be like another
chance
[Music]
I miss this also the theaters
I think it's a dual release it might be
um I feel like only certain theaters
[Music]
okay yeah that makes sense now I hear
all the voices
Dennis Hazel I thought he was he was
zipper yeah
who is Tim Robinson
nice
Dark Wing say it with me
we do we want Dark Wing
oh man yeah that was good I think they
even snuck a little yorma uh
Cameo at the end man that's great that
was dazzling that was delightful other d
word to complete alliteration Dale rific
chiptacular
Monterey
[Music]
nah it'll come to me on torrageous
monitorageous there you go there you go
there might be a post credit scene
there's some modern day types there's
gotta be there's credit seeds modern day
a meta self-aware post-credits scene
sucks now redo it released post-credit
team cut
releases all right let's talk about it
man's got these out of the way [ __ ]
burning it I'm sure
and Nick's the headphones as well
alrighty that's right we're trying this
out we could hear ourselves this is
weird we're gonna be talking much lower
than usual this is new this is
prohibiting us from being able to be
ourselves this was a bad idea it's okay
you should always try something out when
it's go time yeah don't just experiment
we never have time to test anything so
it's always like let's test it out on an
actual uploaded yeah see how it goes
let's risk this being unusable but maybe
we'll have a new technique
um yeah okay so as established in the
beginning of this I had my my knowledge
of Chip and Dale was about just you know
like what they look like I had when they
made the joke about Chippendales the the
Vegas show and when I first heard
there's a Chip and Dale trailer out
I thought it was about the Chip and Dale
maybe I thought that's exactly where my
mind went I didn't think it was about
chipping I didn't hear it was from
Disney plus I thought it was just
shipping Dale they're like oh they're
doing some movie about the Chip and Dale
show yeah uh so yeah and I didn't know
for a while that oh it's about the the
Chipmunks and so going into this there's
very little things I had heard about it
other than I people with word of mouth
on it was that it was a really good
movie that was great I wasn't aware of
the voice actors wasn't aware of any of
that and as you saw in our reaction if
you stuck around for it we have a
podcast by the way a real rejects
podcast people who are already here for
the podcast like why are you mentioning
this was because it's going up on
YouTube Some people on YouTube don't
know that this can be found on Spotify
Apple music Stitch or wherever you get
your podcast and it would really help us
out if you'd subscribe yeah be cool man
trying to do a little bit more stuff
there
but if you're there here uh which
audience do I tend to all of them are
all welcome here in the reject Nation so
uh yeah I I thought that this film was
really delightful I did not expect such
such a meta Roger Rabbit Vibe uh through
it all it's the plot of Roger Rabbit in
a lot of ways you know like Tunes are
being murdered yeah yeah some devious
scheme is happening in the skeevy part
of Toontown and we gotta figure out what
it is and stop it they they at least
acknowledge Roger Rabbit twice instead
of ever making a direct joke uh about
like uh this is a lot like blood Roger
Rabbit uh that and it's that world of
going through all the characters but the
scope when the Cameo started coming in
was really surprising to me because of
all the different IPS you know and it's
like Roger Rabbit very specific IP you
were dealing with if it's a Warren
brothers movie it's only people in the
Warner Brothers umbrella who you're
dealing with well Roger Rabbit did break
ground in that they have that piano
sequence where uh it's like Daffy Daffy
that's right yeah it was like the first
it was it was a big moment for for a
crossover right right yeah
um but still like this is way you know
further down there's still Bridges a
whole bunch of other types of Animation
style like I love how they made all
these jokes of things you can make fun
of over the years of the evolution of
Animation you know especially with the
back in the day and sometimes movies
still suffer with it that back in the
days CGI dead eyes look of The Uncanny
Valley I thought was awesome uh of all
the different kinds of the stop-motion
animation with the Gumby like yeah and
the way they utilize everything there
seemed to be not just like obvious jokes
but a genuine sense of adoration for it
all which made it that much more
complemented like and I think
aesthetically the choice to make Dale
the 3D animation and Chip to keep him at
his hand drawn animation also worked so
and well like not just as a commentary
of the the way times have changed but
also as a reflection of who these
characters are
two characters who are also stuck in the
past yeah in their own different ways
like Deo looks fondly upon it but is
trying to capture the magic of the fame
and success still yeah so he's like
selling out there's there's Parts it's
funny because there are parts of it that
were weirdly making me think of another
Andy Samberg movie called that's my boy
you know and everyone's favorite out of
there were parts of a Sandler joint too
parts of it were Dale it was kind of
like Andy's was for some reason making
me think of the Andy Samberg and the and
the even that's a father and son story
but the Dynamics of you know having Andy
Samberg and the way chip is portrayed
here that's a R-rated kids if you're
listening to this review don't don't
watch that movie
um now this would be a double feature
yeah maybe actually thematically
unlikely double features are underrated
and whereas chip is stuck in the past uh
but in a grudging sort of way
and uh yeah in a bitter kind of way yeah
I really think like the way they are as
characters is really fleshed out well
and I thought keeping that the center
and the focus instead of doing what a
lot of these movies tend to fail at
where they get so caught up in only
Easter eggs and only cameos and fun
appearances and quick little knots quick
little one-liners they still made it a
story that honored the the the la cop
genre you know I thought it was really
inventive and exciting and funny and the
way they the way they did their meta
commentary was was wonderful like I I
don't have
any issues with this movie at all I
don't even have I don't really have a
single complaint I never found it
annoying or anything no it's like little
nitpicks you can do but I I think that
would just be me trying to find
something that I don't actually have a
problem with yeah I thought this was
pretty inspired overall and and yeah
something I feel like especially I mean
obviously Roger Rabbit is kind of the
Touchstone but there are other things
that blend you know cartoon reality with
real life or animated characters with
real life yeah Space Jam or even the
Sonic movie recently is kind of an
example of that uh and I feel like there
is a tendency and I guess you could look
at Space Jam uh a new Legacy and and
kind of see this happening where it's
like they lean maybe a little too
heavily into like that's a cartoon you
know there are no rules we can have
Reckless abandon for everything and just
dump you know recognizable properties
like it's funny there's so many things
you can sit during this movie and go
it's that and is that instead blinking
you'll miss it and yet somehow I felt
like they really knew where to lean into
the cartoon and when to lean out of the
cartoon and and to take certain aspects
seriously or to at least treat them with
the Credence of characters who actually
care and uh and yeah it it it reaches
this nice
um it was it was like part way in it was
like at that half hour or 25 minute Mark
where I was like they're treating this
like a real movie yeah and they're
letting Chip and Dale their emotional
journey and their relationship story
grow at a very natural pace whereas I
feel like a lesser movie would try and
Fast Track that stuff to get to all the
fun gags and all the fun effects that
you know we want to see and that are so
dazzling to behold
um but yeah it's that uh you know
simplicity at the core of them having to
confront and really understand both
their own feelings about each other as
well as themselves and and open up about
all that stuff but it's also that
they're trying to help you know one of
their immediate team and so while it's
not like being back in the cartoon it
does have this really natural core to
ground it and then you have all the
extra fun around that and yeah I thought
this built it's funny there are a lot of
similarities for Roger Rabbit but I
thought this built really nicely and
Justified its existence by lovingly and
beautifully combining so much and and
really going to show and we were talking
with a friend uh our friend Erica a
while ago who kind of put it to us this
way that like a lot of people mistake
animation for a genre genre when really
it's a medium all unto itself and this
is a really great example of that
because you see hand-drawn 2D animation
from all different eras from like the
hose style in black and white to the
more modern style that looks like it's
done on a computer to things in between
and then you have the claymation you
have this 3D and there are multiple
approaches to all those things so much
so that that uncanny valley I was like
wow you guys left no stone unturned in
really looking at the growth of anime
question in all its different
facets over time and incorporating those
and making those characters feel alive
and and treating each of their realities
or each of their forms as just part of
this world and so that's you know
another thing that Roger Rabbit did
really well is yeah I really believe
that just all these people kind of
coincide together yeah and uh and as
opposed to just breaking the wall and
making some obvious joke yeah it's like
it's weird it's like it is a cartoon but
it doesn't feel as much like a cartoon
as like a lot of other things can
because yeah it's it is like usually I
want to go to that world It Feels So
tangible you know I mean having puppets
too and puppets yeah I was thinking of
the Happy Time murders I was like this
is this is way more palatable than the
Happy Time murders even and it's doing
parts of what that movie kind of tried
to do well I love that the way it was
shot had such specificity to it it
wasn't just like some flat looking film
and they I feel like a lot of times you
kind of would but they really
that really had great like Symmetry and
lighting to complement each scene so
when they're blending the animations
even though it takes place in Los
Angeles
whereas not the just keeping this
comparison to Roger Rabbit or it's like
a Roger Rabbit that's in tune town or
whatever right what's it called yeah
there's Toontown I can't remember what
like major U.S city it's supposed to be
kind of a part of well they eventually
get work style really embodied there
where here you stay in La the whole time
yeah yeah and and and I thought that you
know the way they Blended the animation
in there looked seamless it didn't look
weirdly misplaced or just some added on
thing in post it still felt part of a
world yeah to the point that you'd have
like I was noticing that there's moments
where like a CG rendered character or a
3D meant to look like I kept marveling
and wondering how they achieved some of
these things or what their approach was
because like when a CG character picks
up a 2d animated character there's
something about even that where I'm like
you could probably and it probably is
all done in the same effects render shot
on a computer and yet somehow it looks
like you did a layer where there's a CG
character and then you did a different
layer where there's a hand-drawn
character and that again just lends more
and more credibility to the interlocking
and the interplay of all these different
styles and effects and whatnot and yeah
like this was not so slight Akiva Shay
for whatsoever because the lonely island
has always had film style as part of
their repertoire of comedy and I've very
much enjoyed several of the comedies
he's directed with that crew but this
one was one where I was like man the the
choices of lenses and angles to again
lend credibility and to really make you
feel like you are in a detective story
or an LA movie or or whatever it is at
the time or are like really deliberate
and and I forget the cinematographer's
name off the top of my head I mean
that's another you know sort of uh a guy
who's got a lot of big credits under his
belt but um still it was yeah it was so
much more crafted and cinematic than
this movie had to be because I'm sure it
would be very easy to Dish this out and
put it on Disney plus and plop your kids
in front of it but yeah this is like
they I think like a lot of the jokes
kids will get yeah that was I was I was
surprised it's like it is trying to
Plate everybody in in a sense but it's
not trying to be too much for kids to
the point where I was like I feel like
the Ellie character is almost here to
she has this sort of very incredibly
genuine and sort of doe-eyed quality
about her and I feel like that is kind
of the part where it's like okay we
gotta kind of anchor this so it's still
a bit of a family movie but even still
it's got that edge and that sense that
we're not
trying to sanitize it too much and we're
not trying to get too edgy in a way
where it's like you can tell we want to
go further but we can't you know like I
felt like they had a good grip on how
adults could enjoy this and how kids
could enjoy this well the the commentary
they make
a they do a good job with characters
even with sweet pete like that I think
they the way they use their comedy is uh
and the commentary specifically is
through
these characters and how one has is is
hasn't caught up with the times and the
other one is trying to keep up with the
times so the way they do talk about
reboots and those knock off you know all
the bootlegs the latest movies and stuff
yeah the way they talk about those
um the way they do talk about animation
and such is all imbued in in what the
characters are going through in the
moment and like even with the rap you
know like making fun of that the the
idea of reboots yeah like ending on that
note that's almost like an adaptation
ending of talking about what this film
is yeah without ever making it just
something that is talking to the
audience when the when the joke is
clearly a meta joke and I think two you
know even sometimes there's it feels
like it's more fleshed out and has more
depth than the film in it any neat to
really be but never got weighted down or
slowed down by it even with sweet pete
you know I thought that was cool to hewn
a story about him about Peter growing up
and becoming an old bitter man going
through what a lot of child actors going
through like what a lot of child actors
go through and how he becomes the
amalgamation of so many things that have
gone wrong yeah so many things that it's
a crossover adapted and this is a
crossover catastrophe when he's that big
villain at the end IP mishmash yeah the
nightmare that this could have become
yeah yeah I think that's so smart you
know like I think Ralph breaks the
internet did a really good job on
on uh that film I thought did a really
good job on doing all the Disney spoofs
and stuff what I really liked about this
one too was as many IPS as they oh we
gotta talk about ugly Sonic at some
point as many as many IPS as they sweep
across here yeah as many as there are
actually the headphones helped me out
there because I noticed my voice was
traveling here when I was talking there
so I want to follow the base you gotta
Focus my voice here yeah so
um the the uh what we're just saying
before I mention ugly Sonic oh the IPS
yeah uh with the IPS they never went to
unless I totally missed it as some
random Easter egg they never went to
Star Wars and they never went to Marvel
even to DC
but they didn't hone in on doing jokes
that Disney nine times out of ten what
we have Marvel in Star Wars let's do
that and they never went down that path
they're actually respected the restraint
on that yeah it's like they I think they
are in there but it's not and and I love
free guy but it's not free Guy where
it's like oh I can tell the one sequence
where this is after the Disney merger
and now we can do that yeah whereas here
yeah it's like it's so they like those
things pop up but there's so many other
things that are popping up that are
exciting that are featured that yeah get
that attention I don't remember that I
don't remember them being there the Star
Wars is is toward the beginning at the
convention when they cut to the two mice
literal oh yeah yeah but it's but even
that is not the most obvious like you
know it's it's not like Dale pulls out a
lightsaber at some point like you would
yeah imagine a Star Wars nod in a movie
like this to be and I I appreciate two
again you know yeah so Works within
there exactly and that's so brief it's
not the focus and I thought that was
another nice choices is it makes a lot
of sense for these characters to be at
conventions and signing autographs and
whatever and that gives you a chance to
almost have your like goofy Space Jam
background actors who just are people in
Cosplay but then also have the
characters around uh in real form and
yeah it creates a world rather than a
conveyor belt of references like and I
love that in a day and age where it's
like you have Space Jam a new Legacy
where clearly that's Warner Brothers
partially strutting their entire stable
of ips and characters I I am
appreciative and I'm sure that perhaps
the breadth of what Disney owns is
probably beyond what I'm aware of but it
seems like they probably had to pay at
least certain people to use their IPs
there are definitely some Warner
Brothers characters in here and they're
definitely some characters the cards
included in Fox that are in here yeah as
much as there are a lot of fox and other
characters there's DreamWorks too yeah
is
ET they they
um there's a lot and Sonic is yeah and
that's another example of like you know
there's tons of Disney stuff in here but
I appreciate and especially in some kind
of spiritual Roger Rabbit's successor
that yeah they they went across the
aisle paid a little money to other
people to bring the characters together
and and ex I always feel like there's
sort of a laying down of the ego when
that happens yeah because this was about
the animation departments yeah you know
and and I think that gots a lot of
respect and
the fact that they the fact that they
got to get ugly Sonic is so crazy to me
because most of us can remember when
that trailer came out and the outrage
and the fact that they change the design
because of the outrage
um and that's something they like try to
bury like they hid that trailer you know
and and then this character gets to live
on like and be a character and a
different version of Sonic like a
completely different version and still
make fun of that in a way that it's like
a recasting yeah that only works because
of that outrage it's like oh that's so
fun if they gotta make a character out
of this and it's the benefit of of the
outrage of what happened there it's kind
of nuts it's it and and the original
designer the original design of that
kind of gets to live on even though they
tweak it they make them like taller
older fatter creepier creepy creepier
yeah yeah yeah but it's still honing in
on that original design that was
actually a big surprise like that was
one of the most most surprising things
because I was like wow I I want to hear
the conversation that led to them of
proving that on both sides yeah because
that's you know a difficult moment I'm
sure for a lot of animators who worked
on that and for the studio who put that
out and to come in and make ugly Sonic
an actual character and also I think it
works because he helped save the day so
there is a bit of like we're not
punching down too hard like we're we're
acknowledging that ugly Sonic is ugly
Sonic but also as his actual supporting
character in in a movie full of just
blinking you'll miss it you know
appearances as well well it's also like
we're not gonna let your character go to
waste yeah yeah and I part of me hopes
they brought some people back who worked
on the original
ugly Sonic model to do all that stuff
like I hope the animators on this movie
were treated well because that's often a
controversy just among any effects or
you know animation department is like
we're like overworked and
underappreciated and underpaid blah blah
blah so I really hope that in a movie
was such a celebration that the
animators in that department all those
people got to really Embrace and and
feel it the joy that they're delivering
us with the movie it sounds like they
couldn't get Nickelodeon
those are Nickelodeon characters I don't
remember there were some there were some
I mean they definitely it was tell that
whole story with Ellie's background but
I don't recall seeing any characters I
don't there probably are I don't
remember them being featured super
prominently as like speaking or featured
characters but there are definitely
um some you know it's like the Squidward
star on the Walk of Fame and they're
they're they're the fact that they're
talking about and they mentioned
Nickelodeon and yeah there are a number
of I think even on the bootleg while
they're I think like Jimmy Neutron was a
Nick show and yeah there are definitely
nickel there's a Nickelodeon presence
it's just not maybe the most prominent
one yeah yeah well yeah this was uh this
was a surprise I thought I thought like
we've been walking and so many people
said it was good but I didn't know what
it was about and much about it and if
someone wasn't a Chip and Dale fan uh
growing up not because they didn't like
it just never watched them
um what channel were they on
Disney
or a cable channel Disney Channel or is
it interesting watch it in the morning
because yeah there was a block where it
was where it was oh God what was it it
was the Rescue Rangers like Darkwing
Duck and uh
DuckTales I'm not sure I feel like they
might have been on the Disney Channel
but I but it could have been like an ABC
Saturday morning block or something like
that or maybe they played in both places
for the longest time there's only one TV
in the house
that didn't I just didn't watch it but
this was great and
um I I hope people I help people watch
this movie because this was awesome this
is an awesome movie this was really
awesome yeah it's one of the best things
I've seen all year absolutely yeah this
brought me a lot of Joy I can't wait to
watch it again I can't wait to show it
to people and two I appreciate like I
thought the voice cast did a really good
job because it's easy to fall in the
whole of having a bunch of celebrity
voices and not having it feel like a you
know not missing actual voice actors and
I know that there are probably arguments
to be had about who gets included in a
movie like this but I feel like they did
have some also classic voice actors
lending their talents as well definitely
definitely but yeah even the celebrity
cast I thought was really well chosen
like Eric Bana I was sitting there going
is that
I'm sure is that and I didn't even
recognize until the end yeah yeah so all
right guys well
what did you think about Chip and Dale
Rescue Rangers movie leave your thoughts
down below
is your childhood satisfied I mean mine
is mine is without
it this is the best so much how much is
the best possible outcome for this uh
hey let's do a patron of the Doge
Everett pixel might Baker if ever a film
demonstrated the might of pixels
it's probably this film plus there was a
baker in the movie he was a shady guy
but he was bacon and he had bread no
matter how many illicit weapons might
have been hidden in the Bread Everett is
a is a shady individual Everett as well
is the Shady if you were a cartoon you
would be like one of those cartoon
robber guys with like you know the
beanie hat and the five o'clock shadow
and like you know one gold tooth in real
life though he's a cult leader mm-hmm I
would fall crazy part I wish you would
tell me where your compound is
I'm sorry I really set you over a dark
joke and I think I've went too dark
there because of where you went kids
Love Cult jokes though I know I've the
kids are watching these Netflix
documentaries about cult leaders yeah
man and I and I ever might be featuring
one of them one day and I just thought
it'd be cool to be like you know people
were like hey I saw Charlie Manson once
at spawn ranch when I was riding a horse
I thought like it mentioned that we know
Everett we Cypher pixel might be used to
subscribe to our baby shark before we
killed the crazy stuff yeah oh man but
he gets all these hot girls yeah man
he's following him yeah people love a
crazy person I just don't understand
it's just he seems like so passionate he
knows what he's talking about and it
just makes you feel like you're the only
person in the room sometimes I'm there
and I'm like you're talking directly to
me when there's like a hundred hot women
there like and just just you random dude
yeah
yeah so you're not hot at all so if you
feel hot when you talk to ever Baker
that's the strange thing he's got this
power It's ability to just connect
I do
terrible things
terrible awful unspeakable things but
hey you do what you have to for love am
I right for the love of Everett Baker
these headphones
I know right they they are drugs
or let's do ASMR what happens
when we can hear the sound of her all
right
and Whisper really low
you can hear the inside of our mouths
every breath
I was in the video before we blow
people's eardrums out
[Music]